37 ans après jeanne moreau est de retour
dans les sous-sols du palais des papes
elle retrouve aujourd'hui les mêmes
angoisses qu'elle a connus débutante
dans la tragédie du roi richard ii venu
une première fois par amour pour gérard
philipe
elle revient aujourd'hui par amitié pour
antoine vitez héritage que m'a dit un
jour j'aimerais bien que jeunesse se
quitter livre jeanne c'est toujours un
sentiment d'amour mais ne comptez pas
sur elle pour la sensiblerie le palais
des papes et ses fantômes ne
l'impressionnent plus sérieux j'ai
trouvé beaucoup j'ai l'impression que
c'est un autre chaque soir je veux qu'on
m'oublie
il n'y a que célestine vieille mère
maquerelle paillardes qui gravite sans
cesse la tour de babel inventé par
yannis kokkos y diable me dsl oncle avec
les certitudes et les désirs de tous une
sacrée performance physique quand jeanne
moreau qui pendant que quatre saute
d'une marche à une autre et se délecte
avec le texte de perlando des royals
cette année en avignon on ne dit pas
êtes vous allés au palais des papes
mais avez-vous rendu visite à célestine